(Sonic Boom)
I don't know what to say, really.
Three minutes...
...to the biggest battle of our professional lives...
(inspiring music begins softly)
...all comes down to today.
Now either,
we heal...
...as a team
or we're gonna crumble.
Inch by inch,
play by play,
til we're finished.
We're in hell right now. gentlemen.
Believe me.
And...
We can stay here, get the s*** kicked out of us,
or...
we can fight our way back
into the light.
We can climb outta hell,
One inch at a time.
Now I can't do it for ya.
I'm too old.
I look around, I see these young faces, and I think...
I mean...
I made every wrong choice a middle-aged man can make.
I, uh,
I pissed away all my money,
believe it or not.
I chased off anyone who's ever loved me.
And lately,
I can't even stand the face I see in the mirror.
Y'know, when you get old in life,
things get taken from you.
I mean that's-- that's-- that's-- part of life.
But...
you only learn that when you start losing stuff.
You find out, life's this game of inches.
So is football.
Because in either game,
life or football,
the margin for error is so small, I mean...
one half a step too late, or too early,
and you don't quite make it.
One half-second too slow, too fast,
you don''t quite catch it.
The inches we need everywhere around us.
(Hell yeah!)
They're in every break of the game,
every minute, every second.
(Cheers, claps)
On *this* team, we fight for that inch.
On this team we tear ourselves, and everyone else around us to pieces...
...for that inch.
(louder cheers, claps)
We claw with our fingernails, for that inch.
Because we know...
when we add up all those inches,
thats gonna make the f***ing difference,
between *winning and losing!*
(even louder cheers, claps, hoots)
Between LIVING and DYING!
I'll tell ya this, in any fight,
it's the guy, who's willing to die,
who's gonna win that inch.
And I know, if I'm gonna have any life any more,
it's because I'm still willing
to fight --and die-- for that inch.
Because, that's what LIVING IS.
The SIX INCHES... in front of your FACE!
Now I can't MAKE ya do it.
You gotta look at the guy next to ya,
look into his eyes,
now I think you're gonna see a guy who'll go that inch with you.
(Hell yeah!)
You're gonna see a guy...
who will sacrifice himself for this team
because he knows, when it comes down to it,
you're gonna do the same for him.
(Yeah!)
That's the team, gentlemen.
And...
either we heal, NOW... as a TEAM,
or we will die,
as individuals.
That's football, guys.
That's all it is.
Now,
what are you gonna do?
(Epic, enthusiastic raucous)
(inspiring music rises)
(brand sound)
(sonic boom)